U
AS ALWAYS.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
JAN ONE ON A BUSY TUESDAY NIGHT.
THE UNITED STATES OF FEAR IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
THE PRESS AND THE PARTY THAT
THEY REPRESENT WANT YOU TO BE
AFRAID.
I AM TALKING VERY AFRAID.
COVID SUB VARIANTS ARE HERE.
THEY ARE SUPER-DUPER CONTAGIOUS.
CONSIDER CHANGING YOUR TRAVEL
PLANS IF YOU ARE THINKING OF
ATTENDING BIG EVENTS.
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S MORE
VARIANCE SPECIFICALLY SUBAREAS
OF OMICRON CIRCULATING AND MORE
OF US ARE VULNERABLE FOR
REINFECTION.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE FALL
AND WINTER AND PREPARING FOR A
VARIETY OF SCENARIOS.
THIS IS DIFFICULT IF WE GET A
RESURGENCE OF THE INFECTION.
>> VERY, VERY SCARY.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN THEY WANT YOU
TO BE AFRAID BECAUSE THEY WILL
TELL YOU YOU WILL BE
INDISCRIMINATELY KILLED FOR NO
REASON OTHER THEN THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN.
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC OUT THERE OF
POLICE INVOLVED SHOOTING.
>> WHAT EXACTLY WILL IT TAKE TO
STOP THIS LEVEL OF EXECUTION
STYLE KILLING OF BLACK MEN AND
BLACK WOMEN AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
>> THIS NEEDS TO BE AT THE TOP
OF THE LIST FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ADDRESS WHITE
SUPREMACY AND THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND OUTSIDE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
TARGETING BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE.
DIMMICK THAT'S AN UGLY LIE.
THE TRUTH IS THE SUSPECTS DO NOT
RESIST ARREST.
THEY DON'T RUN AWAY AND THEY
DON'T TURN AND LOOK LIKE THE
FIREMAN OR POLICE.
THE CHANCE OF BEING INJURED, LET
ALONE SHOT BY A POLICE OFFICER
IS INFINITELY SMALL.
BUT STILL THEY WANT YOU AFRAID
AND NOT TRUSTING OF ANYONE IN
UNIFORM EVER.
AND OF COURSE THEY WANT YOU
AFRAID OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
HELLO.
I HAVE CHILDREN WHEN THE PLANET
WILL BURN UP AND FLOOD?
YOU NEED TO RETHINK YOUR
CLIMATE.
>> CLIMATE IS CODE RED.
WE HAVE TO TAKE ACTION.
>> WE HAVE SO LITTLE TIME.
WE NEED TO THROW EVERYTHING AT
IT THAT WE CAN.
>> THEY WANT YOU SO PANICKED
THAT IN THE END YOU WILL BE
TOTALLY FINE WITH TRAVELING
LESS, PAYING $6 OR $7 OR $10 A
GALLON FOR GAS.
THEN YOU CAN BLAME GAS STATION
OWNERS WERE PRICE GOUGING.
OVER THE WEEKEND PRESIDENT BIDEN
TWEETED, A COMMENT FOR MOSTLY
MOM-AND-POP SHOPS THAT ARE JUST
TRYING TO GET BY NOW, SAYING
THIS IS A TIME OF GLOBAL WAR AND
GLOBAL PAIR.
BRING DOWN THE PRICE YOU ARE
PAYING AT THE PUMP.
AND DO IT NOW.
IF THIS IS BIDEN'S ANSWER TO
HIGH ENERGY PRICES, THE MAN IS
TOTALLY OUT OF GAS.
THEY ALSO WANT YOU AFRAID OF
SPEAKING YOUR MIND BECAUSE IF
YOU DO YOU COULD LOSE YOUR JOB,
LOSE YOUR PROMOTION, LOSE YOUR
BOARD SEAT, LOSE YOUR SPOT IN
COLLEGE AND EVEN A POSITION IN
THE U.S. MILITARY.
CHILLER POSTED A MEDIA POSTING
MILITARY LEADERS WERE MISTAKES
MADE DURING THE WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND DEMANDING
ACCOUNTABILITY HE WAS RELIEVED
OF DUTY.
TODAY'S DECISION TO STOP
PUBLISHING SIX DR. SEUSS BOOKS
COMES AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN
CRITICIZED FOR SPREADING RACIST
IMAGES.
SPENT THERE'S A SMALL BUT
GROWING REVOLT OF ARTISTS
SCRUBBING THEIR MUSIC FROM THE
PLATFORM.
THEY TOOK ISSUE WITH THE JOE
ROGAN EXPERIENCE.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA
SAID IT DISENROLLED 49 STUDENTS
WHO SIGNED UP FOR CLASSES BUT
THEN FAILED TO PROVIDE A VACCINE
CARD.
>> AFTER THE HORROR THAT WAS
VISITED UPON HIGHLAND PARK
YESTERDAY, THEY EVEN WANT YOU
AFRAID OF ATTENDING PATRIOTIC
CELEBRATIONS.
A FOURTH OF JULY TRADITION IS
JUST TOO DANGEROUS GOING
FORWARD.
>> FROM THE SHOWING THAT THERE
ARE NO HOLIDAYS FOR MASS
SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA.
>> WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING NOW.
NO COMMUNITY IS SAFE.
>> A WEALTHY SUBURB OF CHICAGO,
OF MAYBE THE QUINTESSENTIAL
AMERICAN CITY IN THE HEARTLAND,
ON THE 4TH OF JULY, AT A PARADE.
IF YOU ARE NOT SAFE THERE, WHERE
ARE YOU SAFE?
>> OKAY.
THE SHOOTING HAPPENS EVERY
WEEKEND BY THE WAY IN CHICAGO,
ST. LOUIS, BALTIMORE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FREAKED OUT
VIEW ON THEIR FACES.
BECAUSE IT'S HIGHLAND PARK,
YEAH.
USING THIS EVIL ACT TO WIPE OUT
PATRIOTIC TRADITIONS WHICH WE
KNOW IS ULTIMATELY GOING ON IS A
NEW LOW EVEN FOR THE LEFT.
OF COURSE, THEY WANT YOU ALSO
AFRAID TO OWN A GUN OR TO APPLY
FOR A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
BECAUSE THEY WILL MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ADDRESS LEAKS
ACCIDENTALLY AS IT DID IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT INSTEAD OF SELLING FEAR AND
DIVISION, WOULDN'T IT BE NICE IF
WE ALL BEGAN TO FOCUS ON
SOLUTIONS?
DON'T PEOPLE WANT SOLUTIONS?
I SENSE THEY DO.
ON THE MASS SHOOTING IN
ILLINOIS, INDICATIONS ARE THAT
ROBERT CRIME WAS A REGULAR POT
USER.
ONE LOOK AT HIM AND TO THE
UNTRAINED EYE HE LOOKS LIKE A
COMPLETE PSYCHOTIC.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYONE LOOK LIKE
THAT.
WHAT CAN REGULAR POT USE TRIGGER
IN YOUNG MEN IN PARTICULAR?
PSYCHOSIS AND OTHER VIOLENT
PERSONALITY ISSUES.
POLICE SAY THAT IN 2019 THEY
WERE CALLED TO THE SHOOTERS HOME
TWICE.
THE FIRST WAS ON APRIL 2019
AFTER A REPORTED SUICIDE ATTEMPT
AND THE SECOND WAS IN SEPTEMBER
2019 AFTER RECEIVING A CALL FROM
A FAMILY MEMBER WHO SAID HE WAS
THREATENING TO KILL EVERYONE.
POLICE REMOVED 60 KNIVES, A
DAGGER AND A SWORD FROM THE
HOUSE BUT THEY SAY THERE WAS NO
PROBABLE CAUSE TO MAKE AN ARREST
AT THE TIME.
JUST RUN-OF-THE-MILL BEHAVIOR, I
GUESS.
MUCH OF THE ONLINE PRESENCE
POINTS TO SIMMERING PSYCHOSIS.
UNDER THE STAGE NAME A WEEK THE
WRAPPER HE POSTED A DISTURBING
MUSIC VIDEO BACK IN 2021 THAT
FEATURED A STICK FIGURE DRAWING
WEARING A TACTICAL GEAR AND
CARRYING A RIFLE.
A NEWSPAPER CLIPPING ABOUT LEE
HARVEY OSWALD WHO ASSOCIATED
ASSASSINATED JFK.
WE HAS BEEN PLANNING THE ATTACK
FOR WEEKS AND DISGUISED HIMSELF
AS A WOMAN TO GET AWAY.
ALL THE SIGNS WERE THERE.
BUT IN A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS, THE
MEDIA SEEM TO BE RECOGNIZING THE
DANGER OF SUSTAINED HIGH THC
CONTENT IN YOUNG PEOPLE, REGULAR
USE AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT ONLY TOOK THEM FOUR YEARS TO
CATCH UP TO WHAT THE SCIENCE AND
ER NURSES AND ACTORS WERE
SCREAMING ABOUT IN PLACES LIKE
COLORADO AND CALIFORNIA.
THEY SAW IT WITH THEIR OWN EYES.
ONE RIGOROUS STUDY FOUND THAT
THE RISK OF HAVING PSYCHOTIC
DISORDER WAS FIVE TIMES HIGHER
AMONG DAILY HIGH POTENCY
CANNABIS USERS IN EUROPE AND
BRAZIL THAN THOSE WHO HAD NEVER
USED IT.
DOCTOR SHARON LEVY FROM BOSTON
CHILDREN'S TOLD TOLD THE PAPER
THE YOUNGER YOU ARE THE MORE
VULNERABLE YOUR BRAIN IS TO
DEVELOPING THESE PROBLEMS.
FOR SOME REASON, JUST THINKING
ABOUT ALL THESE HORRIFIC ACTS OF
EVIL THAT HAVE BEEN PERPETRATED
IN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WE STILL WEEKS LATER DON'T HAVE
A TOXICOLOGY REPORT FROM THE
UVALDE MASK SHOOTER DESPITE
EARLIER REPORTS THAT HE WAS A
REGULAR WEED USER.
WHY THE DELAY?
CONGRESS RUSHED TO PASS THIS
GUN-CONTROL BILL IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE HEINOUS
SHOOTING, BUT WHERE'S THE DEMAND
FOR ANSWERS ON OTHER KEY ASPECTS
OF THE CASE?
NO CURIOSITY THERE WHATSOEVER?
LET ME TELL YOU THIS.
THE MARIJUANA INDUSTRY IS MAKING
BILLIONS ON THE LIE THAT WEED IS
FINE, NO BIG DEAL.
EVEN FOR YOUNG PEOPLE, HEALTHY
PEOPLE, IT COULD BE HEALTHY FOR
YOU, IN FACT.
NO ONE IS ARGUING, NOR HAVE I,
THAT MOST PEOPLE WHO USE HIGH
THC PRODUCTS END UP AS VIOLENT
PSYCHOTICS.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
BUT THERE IS MOUNTING SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE OF THE INCREASE IN
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE AND REGULAR SUSTAINED
CANNABIS USE.
SINCE THE MEDIA WANTS TO SPEND
TIME SCARING PEOPLE, FOCUS ON
SCARING YOUNG PEOPLE AWAY FROM
WHAT?
WHAT WOULD MAKE SENSE?
WHAT WOULD BE HELPFUL?
SCARE THEM AWAY FROM USING THIS
DRUG AS YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU, THE POT
INDUSTRY IS EXTREMELY
WELL-FUNDED.
IF IT'S PROTECTED BY SOME HIGH
PLACED REPUBLICANS.
FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER JON WEINER
SAW A QUICK BUCK TO BE MADE AND
JOINED AN ADVISORY BOARD AFTER
BEING AGAINST LEGALIZING POT.
AND DEMOCRATS LIKE NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS SAYS THE EXTRA
TAX REVENUE FROM POT IS GREAT
FOR HIM.
IT'S DISGUSTING WHEN YOU VISIT
NEW YORK.
BIG WEED USES ITS WELL-PAID POT
PUSHING MEDIA ALLIES IN SOCIAL
MEDIA INFLUENCERS TO TRASH
ANYONE WHO QUESTIONS THE MAD
RUSH TO LEGALIZATION.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
I DON'T GIVE A RIP.
THEY TRASH ME MORNING, NOON AND
NIGHT.
THEY ARE PUSHING POT ON OUR
KIDS.
WE ARE PUSHING FOR ANSWERS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THESE ARE THE EYES OF SOME OF
THE MASS KILLERS WHO HAVE
REPORTEDLY BEEN REGULAR POT
USERS.
LOOK AT THEM.
THOSE IN POLITICS AND IN THE
MEDIA WHO DEVOTE THEIR TIME AND
ENERGY TO FEAR MONGERING ON FAKE
ISSUES WHILE COVERING UP THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE GROWING SCOURGE
OF VIOLENT PSYCHOSIS IN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE, THEY HAVE TO BE
CALLED OUT.
THEY HAVE TO BE DEFEATED.
AND THEN THE PUBLIC HAS TO BE
EDUCATED.
AND PARENTS, THIS MEANS YOU NEED
TO GET INTO THE GAME.
THIS MEANS YOU UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS CAN HAPPEN TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY NO MATTER HOW
WEALTHY YOU ARE, HOW
WELL-ADJUSTED YOU ARE, HOW
MATURE AND TO GATHER YOUR
CHILDREN SEEM.
IT'S TIME T